in this three-part course you will learn
how to code deploy
and test three react applications
nikolay is the founder of ultima qa and
is a popular instructor on software
testing consider leaving a comment with
any react testing tips you learn in this
course we're going to start the first
tutorial by creating a very simple react
application using create react app next
we're going to use react testing library
to write a few unit tests afterwards
we're going to learn how to write
end-to-end visual tests and then finally
we're going to take that application and
deploy it to microsoft azure in the
second part of the tutorial we're going
to learn how to create a beautiful
birthday reminder application with some
static data it's going to be very simple
but we're going to build upon the skills
that we learned in the first tutorial
next we're going to think about a
comprehensive test strategy for this web
application and then finally we're going
to write those tests and run them
against our birthday reminder web app in
the third and final tutorial that's
actually my favorite one and i think
you're really gonna enjoy it as well
you will build a beautiful dev portfolio
website that you can use to show off
your developer skills we're going to
code a lot of different components for
this web application but
the tutorial is mostly going to be
focused around a testing strategy you
will learn a lot of very cool tools like
apple io cypress and just for component
testing and unit testing my name is
nikola advelotkin and i'm a senior
solutions architect and i create
tutorials at ultimate qa youtube channel
on that channel that's where developers
come to learn how to test and testers
come to learn how to develop so what are
you waiting for let's dive right into
the tutorials
all right so let's go ahead and start
creating our react app
you can see that i'm here in a folder
called react web app where i've only got
a license and a readme so let's go ahead
and do an npm init to
set up this directory
and so now we have added our
package.json
if you don't already have it installed
we should install create react app it's
a easy way to create react applications
from facebook
once you have create react app installed
you can actually use create react app to
create a
new react application so let's go ahead
and do that
and we're calling this app my app
wonderful so once
uh that's done downloading and
installing you can see a bunch of
commands that create react app provides
first to get started and they tell us
exactly what we can do is to cd to my
app
and then in my app you can see now if we
open this up
we now have a my app folder
uh has a tone node modules
has a bunch of code here
that we will explore in a moment so
let's actually go ahead and start up our
app
and see what that looks like
and here is the start of our
wonderful little application running on
localhost 3000 that's also pointed out
in the logs here
so the really wonderful thing about
create react app is not only does it
build
us an application that's ready to go and
ready to be modified it even comes with
a test that we can execute if we look at
package.json
we can see that if we run a
npm test command it's going to run
some tests and so what we can do is open
up a new tab here
and
do npm test
and that's going to execute
a unit test here
that we have an app.js
and this test is actually using
a react testing library
but what you can see here is we have a
test
that will render the learn react link
here we use a method called
render
and we are rendering our app component
and
next
you can see that we are using the screen
to get an element by text called learn
react
and then finally we are expecting that
link element to be in the document um
this is a
just expect and to be in the document is
the react testing library
assertion that's fantastic because now
we have a unit test that's already ready
for us and it can run
regardless of whether our application is
up or not so if i close down our app
and then come back here and rerun the
tests
they will still continue to work because
they don't need a server
we are actually going to go ahead and
push this up into ci
so the easiest way to get started with
github actions is to come over here to
the actions tab in your github repo
making sure that you have one created
and then you can come and say a new
workflow
github actions will provide you some
suggested workflows and then notice it
notices that we are obviously using
node.js and so then it can recommend us
a potential workflow
this one right here looks fantastic so
let's go ahead and click it it already
comes with a bunch of steps that have
been configured for us
and the other nice thing about creating
your yaml file here is that you also get
a little ide that you can use
for example
you can see that if we don't do
something right like let's say we do
something like this
the ui automatically highlights anything
that
may go wrong and so it says that we're
missing a runs on here and so then we
can do runs on
and then now it says that the value
cannot be null and then that's where you
supply the value
so this is what our
ci pipeline should look like and let's
go over it step by step by the way you
can see it's automatically gets created
in a dot github slash workflows folder
and then you give your file a name
um i'm calling our ci pipeline ci you
can call it of course anything you want
and then at the very top i am setting
three environment variables
these environment variables
are the screener api key source username
and source access key
they are coming from
secrets
uh variable that is part of github
actions and then coming from the key
called screener api key here source
username and source access key so the
value from here is retrieved and stored
in the
environment variable on the left hand
side so where are these values coming
from let me show you that it's
very intuitive in github actions
you come to settings
scroll down to secrets you can see i
have three keys that have been created
here and inside of them they have the
corresponding values that will then be
set in here okay
next we are saying that we want this ci
to run on push requests and pull
requests whenever we do that to the
master bra main branch
next here we are defining the jobs that
we want to execute we're saying we're
going to run on ubuntu latest uh there
are multiple types of different kind of
vms available for you to execute on and
i'm going to be running on node version
14. you can execute on
other node versions if you want of
course
and then we are using the steps
a lot of these steps were previously
provided for us and i've made some
modifications to help you get started
faster with your ci pipeline so the very
first thing we want to do is install
dependencies
um and here we are doing exactly what we
were doing in our command line for our
application and so we would have done cd
my app right and then done a npm install
however i'm simply using mpmci which is
actually faster in github actions
because it ends up caching our
dependencies so this is the recommended
action to take in ci um next we're gonna
build the app right this was just um cd
into my app and doing an npm run build
to make sure we have a production
version because whenever we do an npm
start here
and our application comes up
here in localhost 3000
and we take a look at our uh react
developer tools we can see it's red and
it says this page is using the
development build of react which we
obviously don't want to use for
production we want to use the c uh we
want to use the production build and so
that's how you do with npm run build
next we're executing our component tests
um after our app is built we simply do
the same thing by navigating to that
directory and running the tests exactly
as you saw before and then finally we
are starting up our application actually
starting the server by doing npm start
and then we're doing a weight on command
that will wait for the app to start up
for up to 60 seconds before erroring out
and we will expand this pipeline as we
expand our testing so
once it's ready um the only reason i
recommended to use the uh ui was to help
you with the intellisense but ultimately
the best way to do it is to come to my
app and then make sure we're gonna add a
uh
github
we're gonna do that github
slash workflows
oops
and then we're going to add a new file
here if you're enjoying this tutorial
and want to support this channel be sure
to hit the thumbs up button for the
video and if you want to be notified of
every time a new tutorial is released
hit the subscribe button let's call it
ci dot yaml
it will look exactly as i showed you
here i actually named it to ci2 so that
we can see
uh let's quit our tests
and do it and do a push
and once we do a push that should start
executing our ci pipeline let's come and
take a look at that
we'll see that i have this new branch
open so let's go ahead and do a pr with
this branch
i made one mistake here i should have
put github workflows in the very root
not inside of my app so what you'll see
is i moved that to the correct location
did another push and so now we have a ci
pipeline that started executing here's
the name called ci2 exactly the name
that we gave it in the yaml file and it
did fail after nine seconds so let's go
ahead and take a look at exactly what
happened
so the air says that we can only install
packages with the package log json
or npm shrimp
json so let's go ahead and fix that
in order to do that what we need to do
is
come to my app and do an npm install
which will create a package log.json
and then let's go ahead and add it
and we can watch our
ci rerun
here you can see we just committed 14
seconds ago here's a little yellow
circle that shows that rci pipeline is
running let's go ahead and take a look
at the details
wonderful so there is our ci pipeline
that is not only able to
build our app and start it up it's also
able to even run some component tests
against it
so if we take a look of where we are in
our testing journey
you can see based on this table that
we've actually got a pretty long way to
go before our app is fully tested it's a
really tiny app that we haven't even
made any functional changes to and so
far the only thing that we know about
this application without testing it
manually is that a url
with the correct text does exist in the
dom of the application
we've validated that with a component
test
which
came
with
our app create react app and we did that
using react testing library and jest
how about actually knowing whether the
url is correct right it may
be there with the right text but does it
go to the right location so let's go
ahead and write up another test for that
the very first thing that we want to do
is make sure that we are running our
test suites here in
and then we can add a test that looks
like this where we say where that we're
testing that a url is correct rendering
our component as before getting our link
element as before however now we are
going to validate that the href of the
link element will contain
ultimateqa.com because that's
where we
want our url to navigate to and then
once we hit save watch this window in
the bottom right
it's going to execute
all of the tests in this file
here the first one passed which makes
sense but the second one failed the url
is correct um it's saying that we
expected
ultimateqa.com but we got react
js.org and that's because we need to
make an update to our application to go
to ultimateqa.com
so let's come here and go to app.js
and we will change the url
to ultimateqa.com
we're going to hit save our tests are
going to rerun and now both of them have
succeeded
also while we're here we
this linked text is no longer correct
because we're not going to learn react
instead we are going to learn testing
so let's put learn testing
and dev
and hit save now
and
our tests both have failed and the
reason that they both have failed is we
can take a look at our logs and it's
saying that it's unable to find an
element with the text
learn react
um and then it spits out the dom for us
here showing
everything that it is visible and of
course this is the text that exists
however
the this exercise also showed us that
having
text as a check in our test is not
really a good strategy because we can
often change the text of our links and
so we can instead use a better strategy
such as supplying a data dash attribute
um and so here we can do a data dash
test id
and we can call it a learn
link
we'll
hit save here we'll come back to
app.test
and now instead of getting by text we
can get by id so let's go and do that
let's give this a run
and now everything passes because we are
getting our element by test id and of
course if we decide to change the text
our tests continue to work
let's go ahead and push this up into rci
here's our commit
and here is our check
we can
check on it back in a moment
so our ci pipeline has executed
successfully which is wonderful
so let's see where we are in our testing
journey so at this point we are we have
now
tested that the url is correct
now how about making sure that our
application actually renders correctly
we can do a this test as well as making
sure that our application looks correct
on web and mobile using two different
technologies we're going to use web
driver io and shift right by testing our
rendered application later in the stage
of the development cycle
and we're going to use visual snapshots
to check our application in different
resolutions in the browser to make sure
that our app is responsive and that it
looks correct on different types of
devices
and for that we are going to use
webdriver io
let's install webdriverio
let's configure web drive io
you're going to get a nice handy
menu that allows it allows you to decide
what you're going to do so we're going
to execute in the cloud using sauce labs
yes
so this will be our username and this
will be our access key
no we don't want to do that which is the
default
once you've selected all the options
now you're going to wait for webdriver
io to install all the appropriate
packages
so once all the installation is done the
only other thing that you'll need to
install is the wdio sync service and so
once you have everything installed this
is what our package json looks like
everything that we added if we look at
the diff you can see we've got a few w
d i o uh services added
for our testing purposes
webdriver io tests by default go to test
specs directory and in here i created a
spec dot visual.spec.js file and in here
we're going to have our visual test uh
this visual test uses the standard
describe it format and then the commands
come from the browser object which is a
global object from web drive io
we navigate to a url
and then we execute two important
commands
first we do an init which will provide a
name for the app that we're testing so
we can say um
my react app for example and then the
next one we're gonna do is um a snapshot
this is capturing a snapshot of the page
that we wanna test and so in this case
it's our home page uh and so we are
calling it home page
so the config file for web drive io
lives over here and
there's a lot going on in here but that
we can take a look at only the important
components so here i've created two
constants called visual options and
source options where i am
setting some api keys here i'm setting
the uh screener api key
i am providing a project name i'll show
you how that correlates to the actual
ui and then i'm saying to scroll stitch
screenshots to enable that to true so
that uh when my apps are pulled up the
entire page is scrolled and stitched
together
next i am enabling
a source connect which is an https proxy
that allows me a secure connection from
localhost into the cloud execution
environment for screener and sauce labs
um
this is telling us where the specs are
for our tests and then finally the most
important part of this i would say is
the configuration to run on multiple
different browsers and operating systems
so i'm running this on two of the most
popular browser resolutions the very
first one is
this one here
on this viewport size which is the most
popular desktop and running on windows
10 and chrome
and then the other type of browser that
we're running on is mac os safari on
this resolution which is an iphone x
viewport size and of course we can have
a lot more resolutions here and what's
going to happen is
our visual spec is going to run on both
of these platforms at the same time
we can of course run it
we can run our tests using this command
here
but instead let's add a test script to
our package json
we can come here and add
and then ensuring that in a separate
terminal you have the application
actually running on localhost 3000
because it has to be up for us to do
end-to-end visual testing we can now run
our visual testing command
at this point we can see that it's
executing two specs and of course that's
our safari and chrome specs let's go
take a look at the screener ui to see
what's going on over there so we can see
that uh here is our new app dash two
that we've started
there are currently tests running
the build has failed and the reason why
it failed is because we have two brand
new snapshots that we've never accepted
before what screener is currently
telling us is that hey i've got these
two snapshots
of
these resolutions of this page here of
the home page and i don't know whether
they are acceptable to you or not so we
can open each one up and take a look
does this look good to us and correct
yes it does we can come here and set
this as a baseline from this point
forward every single automated test will
validate against this version of the
baseline and this is the bigger
resolution here and uh this one looks
fantastic to us as well let's go ahead
and accept it
and so now from this point forward and
new executions will run against those
baselines let's also now add this visual
step to our ci pipeline and see that
execute
here we are back in rci yaml
we've added a brand new step our after
application has rendered to run visual
tests and performing the following
commands let's go ahead and check all
this into ci and see what happens
we've got a new commit here for adding
visual tests and here is our ci pipeline
executing
so here's our pipeline after execution
we can see our visual tests have
executed successfully with a check mark
and if we scroll all the way down we can
see that two tests have passed
so the current version of our
application it's a little boring right
let's make it a little bit better and
actually see the power of visual testing
so we're going to replace this logo with
another logo
by coming into app.js
and we can see that up here at the top
we're pointing to an svg let's change
this svg and instead we're gonna point
to
mia.jpg which is a nice file that i've
uploaded so let's save that and watch
our application render and here is the
cutest little dog in the world her name
is mia and of course we can also even
change
this link right here to be instead of
learn testing we can change it to
something else
we can say
learn testing
with nikolai
and mia
fantastic
our application rebuilt
and this is what it looks like
and we can even run our tests
to make sure that everything is working
as before our component tests
both of them working successfully
because remember we added that nice data
test id attribute and now we can check
in these changes and see what happens to
our visual test
here's our change
in github
let's
see what's going
on so now if we look at the screener ui
we can see that our new app 2 has two
changes let's click take a look and see
exactly what happened
and so what screener shows is two visual
changes that have occurred a screener
uses a smart hybrid div meaning that it
analyzes the dom and element shifts um
and it identifies exactly the two
elements that we have changed and so now
as far as to decide whether this is a
valid change or not and yes this is a
valid change and it looks fantastic and
we want to use this as the new version
of the baseline so we're going to accept
this one
looking at this page here we like all of
the changes here as well and we can
accept that as well
and with all of that said we are pretty
far down in our coding and the testing
journey we've validated pretty much
everything about our application
we validated that the app renders
correctly and that the app looks as
expected
on web and mobile using our visual dom
to database tests also known as
end-to-end tests and we did it with the
following technologies
so how awesome would it be if we can
actually deploy this application and
then test it in a real production
environment well we can actually do that
using microsoft azure and we are going
to use their azure static web apps
feature their azure static web apps
feature is basically a simple way to
deploy applications without having to
worry about infrastructure
and regions and
a bunch of other stuff but it's a you'll
see it's a very easy way to make this
possible so we're going to go ahead and
do that
in order to do this you're going to need
an azure account you can get your azure
account by going to azure.microsoft.com
and it's absolutely free you can sign up
for free and then you can
follow along in the tutorial
next you're gonna need to install an
azure static web apps extension so here
in your visual studio code you're gonna
come to extensions and install azure
static web apps extension
once you have azure static web apps you
will have this little icon azure you'll
come in there you'll come into static
web apps and you'll click the plus
symbol to add a new azure static web app
so here it's asking for
us to provide a name a unique name for
our web app let's call it my
react web app
nexus asking to select the configuration
we obviously have a react project
next it's asking where is the source
code of our application and ours is not
at the root but it's inside of my app
that's where all the code goes
and then finally it's asking where
will your application get built to so
when we come here and run npm build uh
that's the final production version of
the application that goes here into the
build folder and so this here is correct
and that's what we're going to supply
inside of our github project we see that
we have a new action that was added and
it's called
azure static web apps workflow and
basically microsoft azure added a new
yaml file
uh that it's calling right here azure
static web apps blah blah blah
and so then this has a configuration for
building and deploying our application
and so once we open it up we can take a
look at everything that happened here
the longest and most important step was
actually building and deploying our
project if we open it up we'll see a
bunch of stuff that was executed but
ultimately the most important part was
this at the end here where
our web app was actually deployed to
this url which was dynamically generated
for us
and if we click on this url
we will see that here is our beautiful
and wonderful application
live in
production i did have to add one other
thing here
when i checked in the code is there was
a settings.json
that came along
let's see if i can find it here uh that
came along and saw what was very
uh i needed to push that up into my pull
request as well and uh that settings
that json just has these three things
configured as well and then once i push
that up the build works successfully we
can also talk about that
file here that was added for us
it has a lot of stuff going on which is
not really anything important with the
most important part here is basically
that
um
these three parameters talking about
where our app is located and where the
build output is created and so in this
instance it basically just
builds and deploys our job i didn't set
up any of this it was done for me
automatically which is really fantastic
and then here at the end is just a close
pull request the job which basically
once a pull request is closed um
it'll
basically
close out the job for us
so
that's really all that was added here
for us all automatically using using
azure static web apps now how do we
actually write tests for our production
environment let's go ahead and do that
so the very first thing that i want to
do here is actually update our app so if
we run npm start
this this is an okay picture it can
definitely be better
and so let's make it better in our app
so what we're going to do here is come
to my app
in the source
we will
change the picture to a better one so
here we have mia i'm going to rename
this one
to mia old
and rename this one to mia
you can see this one is much better of
my cute little dog being violently
attacked by her boyfriend
fantastic so obviously that's gonna now
load up in our app so there it is
a much better image
and so then with that
change done
we also need to update our azure
pipeline for being able to handle
all of the testing and so to do that
we simply
do everything that i did in this file
so it's basically a merge of the azure
file that we had before that was
automatically created for us by azure
static web apps and the ci file that we
had before and so
all of this you've seen before setting
environment variables um all of this
configured here however now
we have a build and deployed job
i kept a bunch of the
logic that was there from microsoft
azure and then we did all of our local
testing here so installing dependencies
building the app running component tests
starting the app running visual tests on
localhost this is a new step we were
doing it before but i just simply
renamed it
calling it uh run visual tests on
localhost
and you can see we are running npm run
test visual which if we look at
that
here
you can see npmra does
points to uh this config here and then
we're also gonna have test visual prod
which is gonna run the same config it's
going to have a debug higher log level
and it's also going to point at a base
url
so let's continue here in our azure
azure yemo so here is the build and
deploy step that we got from the azure
static web apps i literally just copied
and pasted this in here
uh everything all the same and then the
only part that i needed to add was
adding
visual tests to be executed on prod and
so that's that script that we were using
before however we need to point to a
different url in which url are we going
to use well this one now that we know
our production url we can use it for
testing production purposes
so let's go back to here
we're going to go to our package.json
and we're going to update our script so
we're going to change our base url
to
this right here and so if we're using
webdriver io so that's how we're able to
pass on this parameter here and we're
setting it to our production url
and then this close pull request job
remains just as before and so now
let's go ahead and
give this a run let's stop this let's
see our changes
and don't forget that i renamed our job
to azure c9
and let's push this up
if we come back here to pull requests we
see that we have some checks being
executed let's take a look at those
so here we have our azure ci pipeline
that we just created by updating the
yaml file
let's click on the details
and now we are going to see all of these
steps
and uh let's watch them execute
and then see the final outcome uh-oh
something happened to our ci pipeline
looks like
visual tests failed on localhost do you
know why that is
we're going to figure that out in a
moment
so the reason that our tests failed on
localhost is because remember we made
the change to the image and so now if we
come back here to screener we see that
two have changed
if we look at the changes we obviously
see that the image has changed so
uh this is good for us we don't need to
worry about it it's absolutely the new
version that we want in our application
we're gonna accept everything that was
selected and then we are simply going to
rerun this job and now everything should
pass successfully
wonderful our build has finished
successfully so let's go ahead and
actually take a look at everything that
that's happened
uh here was just some actions that we've
already seen
we've seen installing of dependencies
building the app
running component tests starting the app
and then here is the visual tests on
localhost
those have succeeded because we finally
accepted a new baseline right we can see
that
one has passed on chrome and windows and
the other one on mac os
next we have the build and deploy task
here that was using the azure static web
apps
uh action
and that all succeeded successfully if
we scroll down we'll be able to see the
url to which it was displayed too
and then finally we run our visual tests
on production which is pretty much the
same thing except we are just running a
different script right a test visual
prod and you can see the web driver i o
configuration that was enabled here
pointing at that url to which we
published and the tests there passed
successfully
and that's pretty much it we've
successfully created a ci pipeline that
not only tests our application but then
deploys it to production and retest
you can now go ahead and make 100
million dollars on this application
so just to summarize in this tutorial we
created a very simple react web
application using create react app we
then created component tests using react
testing library
afterwards we shifted right by creating
automated visual tests
using screener and web drive
we added the code to a ci pipeline using
github actions and then finally we used
azure static web apps to easily release
all of that code into the microsoft
azure cloud so that our application
lives in the production environment and
we can test it there
my name is nikolai holakin you can learn
more about me at ultimateqa.com and it's
been a true pleasure being able to show
you all of the skills today have a
wonderful day
hey and welcome to building a birthday
reminder application with react js in
this tutorial we're going to code a
react application from scratch
next we're going to consider a wonderful
testing strategy for our application and
finally we're going to implement a
single test that's going to provide us a
ton of coverage on our web application
my name is nikolai at vlogkin and on
this channel i help asdas all over the
world
build
test and deploy applications in a
continuous
manner
if you
want more amazing content like this
be sure to smash the thumbs up button so
that i continue creating content for you
so grab your computer grab your coffee
and let's do this
all right so you ready to get started
let me put on my
magical coding glasses
and let's begin
so
the code base that we are going to be
working on is going to be coming from
this project right here
you can see it's a fork of this other
project that has a bunch of
react web apps and we're building on top
of those by
teaching about how to test and deploy
them
we're going to be working on this
birthday reminder
there are two folders here there's a
setup folder
and there is a final folder the final
folder is basically
what the code is going to look like at
the end and the setup folder is what
you're going to be working from it's a
blank folder
to get you started
and it's going to have some
boilerplate code in there and then we
are gonna code out the rest so let me
show you exactly what that looks like so
of course first step you're gonna get
clone
you can if you want you can fork my
project and then do a git clone
and once you have that down you'll
navigate to
the final directory
so i'm just gonna do that and then i'm
gonna do an npm install and start
so that we can see what the final
version of the application will look
like
all right so there it is you can see
our application is running of course on
localhost 3000
and this is what it looks like
it shows the birthdays that we have
today
the people whose birthday it is and if
you press the clear all button
it uh clears all of the birthdays
that's really about it the app is super
simple however we have to get started
with somewhere simple and build up and
along the way we're gonna figure out not
only how to code it but also how to test
it
so now that we know what the application
looks like
let's go ahead and implement it together
and then afterwards we're going to talk
about the testing strategy
so i'm going to kill
this over here and you're gonna follow
along with me so you're gonna
navigate one route up you're gonna
navigate into setup
and that's where we're gonna be working
from
also
i am going to change to a new branch
we're going to work from birthday
tutorial
if you want to follow my commits you'll
see those in that branch
so obviously we have the source folder
if you're in setup you'll also need to
do an npm install
while that installs we can talk about in
app.js you can see there's nothing here
except this h2 that says remind the
project setup
in this data.js
you'll see it's just an array of
metadata about each one of our users
just again keeping it simple
not needing to pull it from anywhere
right now
our index css already has all the
styling right we don't want to spend
hours
putting together all the styling for our
application so it's already here and
ready for you all we have to do is
implement it i'd rather spend more time
actually implementing projects and less
time worrying about css
um in index.js this is our entry point
for our application and then our list.js
will
contain
um the list of users
and we're gonna iterate over them and
you'll see exactly what we're doing here
but in the meantime
everything should have installed and if
we do npm start
it'll pull up our app and i am actually
going to pull this out
we'll put this side by side
with our editor so it makes life easier
and we'll put this over here just like
that so you can see
what this is showing right now it's just
a our app.js it's just a
simple pink background uh with a header
that says reminder project setup
let's go ahead and start coding
all right so let's start doing some work
on this application we're going to start
working out of app.js
let me go ahead and close the window on
the right just so you can see more space
here
and we'll close this down here as well
so
with that
we are going to get rid of this
and we will return a much larger block
of code
and now we are going to add a main
element and why its main if we come into
our index css
we'll see that the styling for the main
component is over here that's going to
be the wrapper
for our
main portion of the application and
inside of that we're gonna have a
section
and this section is gonna get a class
name
and that's going to be called container
so as soon as i save you can see
exactly what this looks like
again if we look at the index
find container
you can see that
css styling for the container is right
there
inside of this section which is the
white part right what are we going to
have in there well we're going to have
an h3
and that's going to display the amount
of birthdays
so far we're just going to do everything
static and then make things a bit more
dynamic
so we'll do something like this save it
boom see that come up right there
next we're going to import our list
component so you can see the import is
already on top on line number three
and that is going to be dynamically
generated once we put the logic in there
so for now
that's all that looks like because
if we look at list you can see that this
is all it has for now
next
we are going to add a button
so
button
and then we're going to do an on click
method right what is it going to do on a
click
so what is it gonna do on click for now
again always keeping it simple let's do
an anonymous function
and that's not gonna do anything and
instead
it's simply going to do
a console log
just like that
and let's give this button
title
and save that and boom there is our
button
and if we come here and inspect
scroll down
go over to the console
and click it
you can see that it says clicked because
that was the method that we coded by the
way if you're wondering how i quickly
created an anonymous function that was a
keyboard shortcut a nfn
so you can type
this a nfm
and you can see it's an anonymous
function and then when i hit tab i get
this automatically generated
and that comes from
there it is this extension right there
beautiful so
app.js so far is up and running
now let's go ahead and fill it with the
actual users
all right so next step we're going to
work out of our list component
our list component is going to contain
all of the birthdays that are coming
from
data.js right so you can see it contains
the name the age
the image
and an id
and this list is just going to basically
iterate over all of that and
list those components
so with that said let's get rid of this
heading
and instead we're going to keep the
fragment here
we are going to
do a map and actually
what we'll want to do is
inside of this list
we're gonna pass in an object that we're
gonna call people okay
using this object
we are then
going to do a map
and inside of there we're going to do an
another anonymous function
and then we're going to map over
a person
and for every single person
we can
destructure that object
have a deconstructed object
and it's just gonna take in each of the
properties of our
person so we got the id
there you go
next
we're going to want to return the
component
that's going to be an article
and inside of that article
we are going to have an image
it's going to have a source
of image
you can see automatically how
those destructure properties are coming
back here
give it an alt
it's gonna have the name of the person
beautiful
and then
below and then we're gonna add a div
and that div is gonna have an h4
and that's gonna be the name of the
person
and then
we're gonna have a paragraph
and then that's gonna say the age and
years
just like that
and then up here
in the article
we definitely want to have a
key for the map so that's going to be
the id
and then we want to give it some styling
which is going to be person
so again if we look at index.css
and we look for
look for person
there is that styling for the person
let's go back let's save it and see
exactly what that looks like
oh it failed let's see what's wrong here
and i think the reason for that is we
haven't passed in any object to our list
component and so that's why it's
undefined and so now if we come back
here
we can actually define it so the very
first thing we're going to need
is a destructured array so let's do that
and that's going to be people
set people and that's going to do you
state
and it's going to take in the data
that we are getting from here
there you go
and then using this information what
we're going to want to do is obviously
update this one to a dynamic value
so that'll just be people dot length
so now we'll show that dynamically
and then our list
we're actually going to want to pass in
the value of people
and that's gonna be people
beautiful
and i think that's correct let's give
this a run a save boom
there it is
there is our application you can see
exactly how it looks and how each of the
components
came into play from the list so
we've got everything wrapped in an
article each one of these is an article
inside of that we have an image and then
we have the person's name and then the
aging years
all that's left is to actually make the
button work which currently is just
console logging
well and making that happen is
extremely easy
and it only takes a single method so
that's just
setting the people
and
inside of that we are just going to pass
an empty array
which is going to clear everything right
so if we save that
and now we should be able to click this
button
and you can see that now it says your
birthdays today obviously the counter
being updated
from
this
the list of people values
being passed in from here into
here and then the on click is using the
set people method from above passing in
an empty array
our application is done now how do we
actually test it
so
we now have our web application it's
there and ready and the question is
well how are we actually going to test
it what is the most optimal strategy
our web application contains
multiple
components that need to be tested there
is for example the dynamic birthday
counter that we coded in the logic for
that obviously needs to be correct
there's the clear all
functionality of the button that needs
to ensure that the list is clear
and then probably the most important
part is the look and feel
of the entire application
on web
and obviously mobile is also important
so how are we going to test our
application to ensure that everything is
functioning as expected so let's start
working through the testing pyramid and
see which approach makes sense
we're gonna start at the very bottom the
unit test layer
unit tests are really great for
low-level types of tests right if you're
having like
functions to
add integers for example or
a function that performs some parsing
of some data
those types of tests are really good for
unit tests and honestly
for most
react web applications unit testing is
rarely ever necessary unless you have
some
deep
javascript logic that you need to test
so unit testing are not going to apply
here because it's not we're going to
need too many unit tests
and also they're not the right use case
here
what's likely better and more applicable
for web applications especially in react
are component tests component tests are
a level higher they ensure that
the
look and functionality
work together that the component that we
created such as the list component is
functioning correctly tied to all of the
back-end code
so if we had component tests
we could have a component test for a
list and then that would
ensure
that when we pull in the data from the
data.js that it's being correctly pulled
in and displaying the correct counter we
could also in have a component test for
the button
and ensure that when we do the on click
method that the button performs the
correct operation
but
what about the look and feel of the
application how do we check that that is
working and looking correctly
we could definitely
move up another level into end-to-end
tests right end-to-end test make sure
that everything from the dom to the
database is behaving correctly
we can click a button using an
end-to-end test and ensure that when the
button is clicked it's actually clearing
all of the functionality
however
still how do we ensure
the visual correctness of the
application
and what if i told you that there was a
really cool strategy that we can use
it's going to be
to validation points in a single task
and we can ensure 100
working functionality of our application
let's go and make it happen
all right so
we actually no longer need to show
the application here so we're just going
to go ahead and
stop it so that we have full screen
and the technologies that we are going
to use for our testing is webdriver io
and screener so we're actually going to
perform a visual end-to-end test that's
going to allow us to render the entire
application make sure that it looks
correctly and then we're going to clear
the entire list and make sure that that
looks correctly and with those two
validation points opening the
application make sure it's in the right
state clearing the button make sure that
it's in the right state
will ensure 100
coverage of our application
no and leave us knowing super
comfortable that
nothing is wrong with our app so let's
go ahead and get started installing the
code so we're going to do npx wdio
and oh and let me make sure i'm in the
right directory
first so let's see d21
and then we're gonna cd to setup
and then we'll do npx
webdriver io
like that and then it'll take us through
a
super user-friendly
installation process
it'll let us pick a bunch of
dependencies
while it installs i'll tell you a little
bit about webdriver io uh webdriver io
is as it says here next gen browser and
mobile automation test framework for
node.js it's really good for end-to-end
testing
with browser and mobile
so if you're looking for a solution that
can tackle web and mobile at the same
time plus it has other
capabilities like being able to plug in
with visual instrument testing tools
such as screener
webdriver io is the right tool for you
so
next we're gonna answer a few of these
questions where's the automation backend
located we are gonna be using running in
the cloud using sauce labs because sauce
apps is integrated into a screener we're
gonna need sauce apps i have an account
if you don't definitely go ahead and
sign up at saucelabs.com
grab your free account there
and i'll show you how to set up that so
it's already asking me about the
environment variables for my username
and access key for sauce apps and yes
mine are saved in sauce username and
access key in my bash profile just like
that no we don't want to run headless
tests
in reach region we're going to do us
which framework mocha is fine there's
also jasmine and cucumber options no we
don't have a compiler our specs located
yup default i'm just hitting enter for
most of these yeah let's have
webdriverio generate some test files for
us just so we can look at exactly
what those look like page objects no
thank you that's way overkill for our
testing purposes here
spec reporter is totally good and then
the services that we're going to install
sauce service we don't need the chrome
driver service chrome driver services
for running tests locally unnecessary
for our purposes because we're only
going to be using a single visual
end-to-end test to tackle all of our
problems and then i'm going to hit enter
here base url
and installing i don't know what it is
about typing on camera
you guys make me nervous whenever i have
to type on camera i forget how to type
okay beautiful so it says successfully
set up our project
right in birthday reminder setup
let me just show you a few of the things
that were added
package.json was obviously updated
with
webdriver i o
we also got the config for webdriver io
and we got an example test
here let's actually open that up
that we can see what that looks like
it's a very simple test navigate to this
url and then looks like it logs in uh
let's actually give it a run using npm
run wtio
[Music]
and we'll see exactly what that looks
like so there it is starting up
we pull up saw slabs here
alright so we see that a minute ago i
had this test executed called
my login application
and we can open it up
and the coolest part is just running the
video and seeing exactly what happened
so there it is there is our functional
end-to-end test
so we know our environment is set up the
next step we actually need to do is set
up screener so that we can do
visual end-to-end testing instead of
functional end-to-end testing
so let's talk about
the configuration for web driver io and
how to integrate it with screener
so at the very top i've set up a visual
options object and that's taking in an
api key and a project name the api key
is coming from screener i'll show you in
a moment and the project name basically
just corresponds to
the project that we're working on and i
named it birthday reminder we also have
sauce options here as well and those are
also taking in a username and access key
you can see all i have three environment
variables here
if you want to get your environment
variables in account user settings
you'll find your username and access key
for sauce and screener which is our
visual end-to-end testing tool
once you log in and then you go to your
account and click my api key you'll get
that api key as well save them all to
your bash profile and now we can easily
do ci cd
and testing on our machines
a bunch of this was already here
i just cleaned it up some more you can
actually even see
in my div
what i've changed just cleaned it up
made it less verbose there's a bunch of
descriptions that were in the web driver
io config to show you everything that
was going on
but the most important components
are this service portion
that i added this allows us to create a
secure connection from
the screener cloud
to
our local machine right our application
is running in localhost and so they need
to be able to talk to each other to
perform the appropriate validations so i
enabled that service here
i added
these capabilities to be able to point
to the screener hub
and finally
i have an array here that will allow me
to run across as many browsers and
operating systems as i want currently i
have it set to desktop
this one is the most popular desktop
resolution
currently
and so
i set it to that resolution set it to
raman chrome windows 10 and latest and
then passing that viewport size we can
add more of these capabilities to run
across more browsers and operating
systems and of course we can also change
this part up if we want so
that's the configuration
what does the test actually look like
let's come back to the test instead of
showing me let me show you that here
here's what the test actually looks like
it's uses the standard describe it
format i'm saying describe my birthday
reminder app
that it should look correctly
next we're navigating to our url here
i'm not specifying anything because the
base url is set in webdriver io config
let me show you where that's that's set
down here
next we're having in a neat command
by the way all of this documentation is
available here in docs
visual and to undocks you can follow
along there it'll help you get set up
but of course i'm here to explain as
well this will just basically start the
execution for the test and then this is
one of the most important pieces is
capturing the snapshot so here i am
capturing a snapshot
and calling it the default state because
this is initially when our application
opens
next after it opens i am going to click
on our button
what i've done here too is add a data
test id attribute to make our bun more
unique and so in order for this to be
possible we have to come back to app.js
and in our button we're going to add a
data test id attribute
calling it clear
so now our button has this unique test
id that we can use
for our identification purposes and
we're going to click it so now that
obviously clears our application and
then we're going to capture another
snapshot of the app
and then we are going to end our test
and ensure that there were no messages
coming back in our results object
let's give this a run and i think you'll
understand exactly what's happening let
me pull up the terminal here
so we are just going to be do we're just
going to do npm run wgio
it's going to start up here
if i didn't break anything
it's gonna start running i think it's
already running but give it a moment
all right there it is it's executing
let's come back to screener and what
we'll see here
in a our birthday reminder we're gonna
see
that currently there is
a session being executed
it's running
on this resolution
here's some information about it and in
a moment i'll show you what comes out of
this i made a quick error there should
be two new states
let me show you what happened it
see how here it can't click on element
data test id because it wasn't found
what i did was i actually modified the
wrong app.js
so we're gonna grab this and put it in
the right app.js in the
setup
folder here there you go
and now we're going to add that button
which is exactly what's running save
that
now rerun these tests
and we'll be back in a moment
all right there it is
two new states just came in for our
application what does that actually mean
well let's open it up and see what
happened
look here you'll see that on this
resolution chrome 95 windows 10 i have
my birthday reminder app this birthday
reminder app has a default state
if we open it up
we see our birthday reminder app here
how does it look
it looks absolutely perfect we have the
correct amount of birthdays
we have all the right people and all the
styling
is absolutely correct that is the best
and most powerful thing about visual
entwine testing is that we can capture
the state and the look of the entire
application in a single command and so
that's exactly what we did here and so
we validated anything that we could have
possibly needed to validate in this
default state right and so this looks
good we are going to accept this this
will be used as a future iteration of
our new code
and the next state is the only other
possible state of our application which
is the cleared state and so you remember
i press the clear all button
and this looks absolutely correct here
as well so not only do we know that the
clear all button functions correctly
which we could have done with a number
of types of tests this test also ensures
that our application looks good as well
all of this logic here is correct and so
we can accept this as well and now what
this means is that any future iteration
of our tests against our application
will validate against these baselines
and check hey
does this look correct or has something
changed in fact if we wanted to make a
change
let's say we went into data js
and
doesn't matter let's remove our very
first element
save that
of course now we're not going gonna have
five
and we wanted we can
run our tests actually let's look at our
application first
look it only has four people now right
and so if we rerun our tests let me show
you exactly what this will tell us
think about it if we're rerunning our
test and it's comparing to the baseline
which functionality has changed and
which functionality remains the same
well the clear all remains exactly the
same so that test is going to pass
and then
the default state that part has broken
and we know we've broken it so i will
see that in a visual test in a moment
there it is check it out exactly as i
mentioned
one changed one accepted let's review
what's
changed see that look it's identifying
exactly what happened one element
removed and this of course has changed
the text and so now we determine is this
correct this correct state of our
application or did we introduce a bug in
this case we introduced the bug
this is rejected
and now we need to go and fix our
application and ensure that it's
looking and functioning correctly so
thanks so much and joining me for this
tutorial i hope you enjoyed building and
testing a
birthday reminder application
i've been nikolai at volatkin so if you
enjoyed this content and you want to see
me
build that application go ahead and
smash that thumbs up button and if you
want to be notified of future video
tutorials
hit the subscribe button and finally if
you want to learn something specific
around react building applications and
testing them
comment down below and i'll be sure to
bring those tutorials to your
youtube feed thanks again have an
amazing day see you next time
today we're going to build a beautiful
next js personal portfolio
website this is what it looks like if
you navigate to nikolai.tech you'll be
able to see a live version of the
application you can see how beautiful it
looks everything here is functional
these icons will take you
to different resources
that
you want people to know about yourself
if you scroll down
you'll see a collection of all of the
projects that you've done you can put
here your testing projects your
development project
anything you've done with the community
at the very bottom you'll see the
technologies that you're familiar with
and show that off to your potential
employers
there is a little section to describe
yourself and who you are and even show a
timeline of your experience and your
accomplishments and at the very bottom
we'll see a personal accomplishment
section that describes
some of the things that you've been able
to do in your awesome career there's
even a
link that you can click and someone will
be able to email you of course also
importantly is this website is
absolutely
responsive so mobile first world it's
absolutely unacceptable in today's world
to have a website that is not responsive
and you can see how our mobile view
looks everything looks wonderful it's
easy to read easy to see you can
interact with everything if you want to
view an application you can click on the
application and then it'll take you
there
all right so with all of that said let's
jump into
building testing this application
so let's go ahead and actually grab the
code so you'll be able to locate the
code at this repository and while you're
there please give the repository a star
and then you will be able to get the
final version of the
portfolio here in this dev portfolio
folder this is where all the code live
so if you pull this down and start the
server you'll be able to see a live
version of the application and i even
created a starter version of the code
for us so if you come to the branches
and search for
dev portfolio
start branch
net and then you can download this code
come to code and download zip you'll be
able to get a starter version of the
application if you come in here you'll
see it's bare bones it's not fully
finished but it's a wonderful place for
us to start and avoid a lot of the
unnecessary boilerplate setup
when you download that branch you can
start your own project of course and
once you start that project just pulling
all of the folders into your new project
and this is exactly what it's going to
look like
in fact what you can actually do
is you can first do an npm install and
then after you do an npm install npm run
dev
and what you'll see is it's actually
going to start up our application on
localhost 3000 so let's pull that up
here and this right here is our starter
application what you can see is it just
has bare bone styling and it has all of
the components that we are going to code
out together so the header the hero so
on and so forth
you can see in our package json we have
all of the dependencies that we are
going to use throughout the tutorial
already set up
and then if we take a look at the source
code you'll see that the bare bones
components have been written so for
example here's what an accomplishments
component looks like already you can see
all it says all it has is a div that
says accomplishments and of course that
corresponds to that component and so on
and so forth so every single component
already is created here just with a bare
bones
div that displays the text and what
you'll also notice just to make this
tutorial a lot more entertaining and
move a lot faster is we've already
created all of the styles as well so you
can see the styles for each of the
components are set up here through css
so all we're gonna have to do is just
code out the actual application and use
the styles where appropriate and we're
not actually going to have to be writing
any of the css i'm also keeping a readme
here for your personal portfolio with
all of the relevant links and
information such as the link to a
personal website how to get started and
a lot of other information that we may
be useful for your
development and testing journey so with
all that said let's go in and start
building our personal portfolio website
so let's go ahead and create our very
first component which is going to be our
header component usually it's easiest to
get started with the simplest component
so we've navigated here to our header js
file and let's go ahead
and we're going to return a container
and inside of that container we're going
to drop a div this is what that div will
look like we'll turn this into a span
and so this is a div that's coming from
our styled components down here you can
see here's the styling that's applied to
this div one and then we're gonna have a
link in here the link points back to
this home page and then we have this gi
css check icon which is coming from
react icons forward slash di and then
we're adding a span that's called
portfolio if we save this pay attention
to what happens on the right we now have
this icon that's clickable if we click
it it takes us back to our home page
because that's where our href is next to
that div we're going to add a div 2
which also of course has its own styling
as you can see over here and we're going
to add several items from that div and
we've got a
project a technologies and about each
one of those having an href attribute
here that doesn't currently exist
but if we save that we now see what this
looks like of course in a mobile view
hovering over all the styling you can
see applied there and of course clicking
it should take each one to the
appropriate section but we don't
currently have these sections enabled so
we'll need to come back and implement
those sections in the future and then
what we want to do is add one more thing
we're adding this social details
component the component is going to look
like this
let's save it
this component is going to contain all
of our social details such as our icons
and you can see here that it's wrapped
in a div 3 and then we have our social
icons and those social icons have for
example a github icon a linkedin icon
twitter icon youtube and so on if you
have other social media that you want to
add you can simply get
any of these icons from react icons.ai
package if you go to their website
you'll see all the different types of
icons and then of course if you wanted
to add others you would simply come here
and add more depending on the type of
social media that you have next the
other thing that we are doing here is we
are storing all of our social urls
inside of this constants file let me
take you there so if you go to social
urls js you can see it's just an object
that contains a link to each one of our
profiles then we are simply referencing
each of the links here
accordingly and so
now
if we come back to header and scroll
down to the bottom and below this div we
add our social
details so you can see the selection at
the bottom it's also going to
automatically import for me so
if i do that and then i scroll to the
top you can see the import was pulled in
for me as well and then as soon as we
hit save pay attention to what happens
on the right hand side boom we got our
social icons you see
and if we hover over them you can see in
the bottom left of my browser it even
highlights the url let me make this a
bit bigger so you can see check it out
so there's that url
linkedin
twitter and
youtube wonderful and in fact what i'm
actually going to do just quickly
put youtube up front take this put it
here save and there we go
let's talk about our testing strategy
for a moment of course we have a web
application that we're building and now
is a perfect time to think about the
testing strategy for this web
application and in a web application
world it's really important to be mobile
first
all our applications now they have to be
responsive and they have to support
mobile so that's the very first thing
that we have to check is
how does our web application respond to
different mobile device resolutions and
so a really good way to do this is to
check
that as we scale down
our browser
to see whether we are finding any issues
and i'm not seeing any at this point i'm
kind of seeing some interesting behavior
at this resolution where
these three are kind of getting clumped
together all right and then as we keep
scrolling i see another issue over here
where our logo is being put on top of
this project's header which of course is
not good to have it's not professional
at all so that's something that we're
going to need to fix
and then of course we can actually get
into actual mobile sizes by right
clicking doing inspect clicking on this
mobile device and then you can select
your device from here i'm selecting
iphone 12 pro
i'm gonna scale it up to a hundred
percent resolution and this is what it
would look like on an iphone 12 pro
looks absolutely fantastic there are no
issues here everything is very readable
and of course we don't have anything
else but besides that that's what's left
and of course you can also check it on a
non-iphone device as well so that's
important and so what we're going to end
up doing actually is writing automated
visual end-to-end tests to ensure that
our application looks good on different
resolutions and we can continue testing
throughout those resolutions as we
develop our application making sure that
there are no regressions as we code our
application the other thing to remember
is that we
added urls
here in these icons right these are the
urls that we supplied ourselves and of
course it's very possible that these
urls can be fat fingered and incorrect
we of course tested them manually
already to ensure that they are correct
but there is no reason to think that
this can't accidentally fail in the
future so we want to ensure that these
urls are correct and also that they're
matching to the correct icon right then
of course we have a
navigation for each one of these items
as well that we wrote in our header so
if we take a look
at our header
js right we
put an href attribute for each one of
these here in the future we'll need to
ensure that they are matching up to the
appropriate section that we're going to
code out here and then of course there's
this portfolio
section that is supposed to redirect us
back to
our home page
which it has this hr attribute and of
course that should be checked for as
well
other than this i'd say there is no
other real testing needs right now and
so this is what we're going to work on
we're going to write automated tests to
make all of this possible so
let's go ahead and do that
we're going to use two tools that are
going to assist us in our automated
testing journey first we're going to use
apple io which is a visual end-to-end
testing tool that allows us to ensure
that our application looks as it should
on different resolutions and you can
even see here actually this is kind of
what happens uh it allows you to take
snapshots and then those snapshots can
be compared against bass lines and then
we're gonna run those tests with cypress
i o cypress io is a functional
end-to-end browser testing tool and
it'll allow us to run our tests and then
of course it will allow us to write our
functional end-to-end tests as well so
let's go ahead and make all of this
happen so in order to save time i've
actually already
installed and set up a bunch of
information here
however if you're doing it on your end
the very first thing that you're going
to want to do
is open up cyprus we do have it already
installed right when we ran npm install
however we're going to want to run mpx
cypress open
and then what that's going to do is open
up a cypress ui
that looks like this you're going to
have way more folders and files that
come out here and it's also going to
create a cypress folder that lives over
here inside of the cypress folder is
going to have several other folders and
several other files that are important
what we're going to do is
delete
whatever
folders and files were in integration
and we're going to create a
visual.spec.js file that's where we're
going to write our visual test we're
going to talk about those in a moment
then inside of the plugins we're going
to want to add
this code to be able to use hapo with
our cypress tests next in the support
we're going to want to import
hapo
cypress
in our commands js file and with all of
that done what we can now finally do is
go to visual spec
and write a test let me show you exactly
what this test looks like
so here
we have a describe block and we're
saying that our visual tests
will display
the home page correctly first they're
going to visit our application and
ensure that our application is in a good
state and finally we're simply going to
get the body of our page
and take a full page screenshot in order
to set all of this up and make it run we
need a apple js file located in the root
of our folder in the root of our project
so you can see here it's right next to
the package json and the cypress json so
this apo js file uh has a number of
important things such as your username
and access key that you can get from
your profile here if you come here and
go to your user profile and account
you'll be able to get that information
then we're supplying a
project name so what we're gonna do is
update our project name and call it
devportfolio tutorial and here is the
most useful part of this configuration
is setting up our targets so we're
basically saying we're giving the
targets a name and then we're saying
which browser
viewport size do we want to run across
there are multiple other configurations
that we can set in this case we're
saying wait until the last
animation has finished in which case
afterwards we're going to take the
snapshot right so here we're doing uh
chrome 1080p
samsung galaxy s10 viewport size we're
doing iphone 12 viewport size and we are
doing the viewport size that caused our
bug that we saw previously how i
determined this viewport size was coming
here and you can see as we scroll down
and actually if we open up our developer
tools
and get out of this view you'll see that
over here in the upper right hand side
it shows us the viewport size that we
scroll so we scroll you can see the
viewport size and then we're going to
look for the problematic one happens at
here there it is there's a problematic
one so you see it's about 650 665 that's
not important so i put in 650 by 415 and
that's where we catch that bug that
we're gonna want to
work on and then the final piece of this
with setting up cyprus is in the cypress
json we set our base url to localhost
3000 and that's how in our visual spec
so if you come to visual spec that's how
we're able to just visit this forward
slash here because of that so now with
all of that said we have a script added
here that we're calling test visual
running the following command let's go
ahead and run it and see what happens
and looking down here we see that
our tests have finished
and let's go take a look at our apple
dashboard so we'll come back here go to
apple dashboard and here we see
that we have this new report
called
dev portfolio tutorial which is exactly
our project name we're going to open up
and we can see our snapshots here right
you can see the different resolutions of
course beautiful you can see our bug
over here we created at this resolution
and then you can see other resolutions
and what our application looks like and
so in these
everything looks good to me
no
huge issues of course except this part
here
and so now we've basically set our
baselines and from this point forward
when we execute these visual tests
they're going to be compared against
this and we're going to need to decide
whether we broke something or we did not
so those are our visual tests ensuring
our application is looking beautiful
across different browsers and operating
systems what about the functional
aspects of our application how do we
actually test those what are we going to
do with all of these links let's tackle
that next
what about all of the links that we need
to check
how are we going to do that in the past
what i would have done would be to use a
visual end-to-end testing tool such as
cypress selenium and i would have gone
identified each of these locators
and then clicked on them and then ensure
that they would navigate me to the
correct url i learned along the way that
that is not the most optimal approach
there's actually a better approach to
doing that the better approach to doing
that that i learned along the way would
be to do something like a component test
a component test also known as a unit
test is something that we can do to
simply check the href attribute of each
one of these elements right if we come
here and inspect each one of these
locators what we see is that each of
these has an href attribute and so if we
know that this url is correct then we
know that it's going to take us to the
correct page
because why wouldn't it the click
ability of a link actually comes from
the a tag and so if the click-ability of
a link inside of a a tag is not working
for you
it's not going to work for the rest of
the internet and so clicking at it is
actually unnecessary what's important is
just one time doing a check that the url
actually works and then after that all
we simply have to do is check for the
href attribute for its correct value
inside of our test now we can as i
mentioned do that through a component
test a component test what it actually
would have done is
if we came to
our social details
we see that we are
passing in a bunch of urls
through
our social urls object here right and so
all of these properties are being set
and then these social urls they live
here
in constance and this is just an object
pointed to your right so we can simply
do something like a snapshot test that
ensures that all of these urls are
correct that would actually be wonderful
it would take milliseconds to execute
it would basically just capture a
snapshot of this file and then if
anything changes about this file it
would let us know that there's a change
and then it's for us to decide whether
it's a breaking change or not the danger
with that and the risk that it doesn't
cover is even though you can have these
urls
that doesn't mean that they are
correctly hooked up
to the correct social icon all right we
could very easily
come here and do something like
github because we were copying we
created one and then we copied and
pasted the rest and we forgot to change
one of them i've done that a number of
times in my life and i am sure that you
have as well and so that connection
piece is actually what's missing and so
in this case what i think is the best
strategy the one that requires the least
amount of effort and has the best
coverage is a functional end-to-end test
and so a functional end-to-end test of
course as i talked about was coming here
checking the href attribute and then
making sure that that is correct and so
to make that kind of test possible what
i've written here is this social details
spec js file
if we take a look at it together and
actually we don't even need either one
of these we're going to save that so
what you'll see here is we are visiting
our url as before
and instead we are saying that our
social details
should have correct social links and the
way we're getting those attributes is
we're looking at each one of our
locators you can see i've used a data
test id attribute which makes each one
of these properties unique and so again
if we come take a look at social details
js
we will notice that each one of these
icons
had nothing unique about it
except the href attribute
so
prior to adding this data test id
attribute all of the social icons look
like this and so how do we reference the
correct one and ensure that it's hooked
up to the correct url and so we do that
by adding a data test id attribute and i
named each one right i said github
youtube linkedin and so on correctly
matching it to the correct icon and so
with that i can now get each one and
assert that each one has a href that
matches the correct value if we come to
our cypress dashboard and we click on
social detail spec it's going to execute
for us
and oh look it has actually failed and
if we take a look we can see that we're
getting a github
and github works successfully but then
if we look at youtube we see that it
failed and why did it fail because
we were expecting
youtube
but instead we got github and that's of
course because i messed up aka fat
fingered aka copied and pasted
incorrectly this url and so if we do
youtube and then we save this
we come back to our cypress test we
rerun it
and everything passes accordingly right
checking github youtube linkedin and
twitter everything is successful and so
ultimately the test looks like this and
i'm not going to write the tests for
the other properties such as these and
the even the logo because you already
know how they should behave and i'm
going to leave that as an exercise for
you to do
definitely send a pull request to the
repository and share with me your
solutions and i will let you know if you
got them right or didn't all right let's
get back to coding the rest of our
application and now we're going to go a
bit faster
all right next we're gonna work on our
hero component which is gonna work our
way down the hero component is this
section of our application right here
so
to make it happen the code is relatively
simple i've already pasted it in we're
going to save it and then you can see
what comes out of it you can see all of
the styles that have been imported they
are being imported from global
components which we've defined in the
appropriate folder because we're going
to reuse them everywhere and so here you
can see we've added a section title all
right that's where my name comes from
you can definitely feel free to add
yours
and then there's a section text
element here
that
allows you to define the text and then
also you can define this button here
i put learn more in fact maybe we can
even change it to yeah about
me
that'll be a better button because it's
redirecting us to about
section of the page which doesn't
currently exist yet but it will in the
future
uh probably will add it under here under
accomplishments it would be
this section about that we would add in
the future
so let's go ahead and say this see how
that text updates and of course all the
styling is automatically coming from all
of these components so now we got this
version of the application let's rerun
our tests right so we can do
two types of tests now that we have
so we can go to package.json right we
can do visual tests like this and then
we can
run cypress tests i'll show you how so
let's run our
cypress test you can do npx
cyprus run
it will actually run them in the
background and then produce an output or
of course you can run them
through
this ui as well so it looks like our
social details are passing which is
wonderful right we haven't changed
anything about our links so that's
expected and then let's do npm run test
visual so that we can run our visual
tests and see what comes out of that
so there we go our tests have finished
running let's grab this url
and check out what's going on in our
apple dashboard so here we can see that
this is a little bit of a different
view now because we're comparing
one check to a pre to a current check
right and so we're checking previous
state versus current state and what we
see here is we have five divs of course
which is great right we can zoom in a
bit so that they're easier to see this
is what
our diffs look like we can put it in
swipe mode and you can see this is the
before and then this is the after right
and of course
the after is
we added an entirely new section and
this is the before and so all of that
just shifted down but in terms of that
it looks good
of course there's nothing wrong here of
course here in this view down here you
can still see we still have this bug
that we're gonna fix in the future
and then we have this section so that
looks good on galaxy s10
everything looks good
this is getting a little bit tight over
here and
this is getting cut off we may want to
take a look at that in the future to see
what's going on and how to fix it and
here everything looks good as well on
iphone
12 pro so no new bugs introduced in a
visual aspect no new issues added from a
functional aspect so of course we can
test the button to ensure that it
navigates to the correct location but we
don't have the about me section yet so
we're gonna do that in the future one
thing we can do if we wanted we could
write a test in we can create a new file
and call this one hero
dot spec dot js and we could have a
failing test
that would be doing something like this
until
we create that feature that's also one
option but we're not going to do that
today just because of a lack of time so
next let's move on to the project
section
next i've gone ahead and implemented the
project section
let me first start running our visual
test right we don't even need to
manually test anymore
we can simply just run our visual tests
and ensure that everything looks good
so i'll let those run while i talk you
through the project component
a project component is relatively large
however it's
not so difficult the main logic
here is really on line 34 where we use
projects.map
and basically that's like a for each
loop where for every single project that
we have stored
inside of this array
and this array looks like this
so you can see we're providing a title a
description an image
the tags the source code
where
to visit the application and then an id
and so you can add as many projects as
you want here right you just keep
appending to the array of whatever you
need
and then
this map function will basically use all
of the values that are coming from that
array
so for example each everything is inside
of a blog card and then you can see
we're supplying image that's getting the
source
then we are having a header that's
getting the title and so the title of
course is this title
we are getting card info which is a
description which of course is coming
from there
and then the tags the tags we also have
to do that for each loop right to go
over each tag and then simply add the
tags and then of course the external
link and another external link with the
corresponding source and visit
attributes so
that's really that and then that creates
this beautiful view that you can see
here on the right hand side of course
totally responsive if you of course want
to add your own projects you simply need
to add all of the images
to
this public images folder and then of
course
update the information for the projects
you can remove projects you can add
projects but leaving these properties in
place you're just obviously changing the
values of the projects so
these tests executed just fine right we
can come here and take a look at a
moment let's run our cypress tests
what do you think are the my cyprus says
gonna pass or fail
well of course if they are
good cyprus tests
they are going to pass because we've
changed nothing about our urls right
everything is
still
exactly as it should be
let me go back and actually
redo them
because we we've updated our
application
so having really good tests it allows us
to update our ui without breaking the
test that is
uh really good solid testing
so and then with all of that said let's
take a look at the apple comparison so
we'll see a new view that we haven't
seen before so here is those here are
those diffs
so again the original
and the new one and of course here it
says we need to review it so we're going
to review it and here are the five diffs
1080p
everything looks great chrome 650 of
course still has the bug because we
haven't fixed it but at least everything
else let's take a look here everything
looks wonderful so everything is being
rendered correctly everything is looking
great there's nothing weird visually
going on and everything looks good and
of course then we can probably expect a
similar thing here and so of course at
this point let's just go ahead and
accept all of these and now they're
going to be used as a baseline for our
future iterations even though we have a
few more sections to implement
all right so i've gone ahead and
implemented the rest of the application
in interest of time so that we can talk
more about testing and of course do the
most fun part which is deploy to
production so that we can proudly
display it to the entire world so i've
implemented a
technologies section
over here
as you can see it's just a bunch of
static text here that's written that
describes all of this information if we
navigate to the technology section
you can see
that all everything is pretty much
hard coded here in this component all
right so in terms of risks
what are the risks with this section
that we need to tackle with new tests
absolutely none actually visual tests
take care of all of the risks there for
us that's the beauty of visual tests
we've written them once and now we can
continuously use them to check on our
application speaking of which let's run
them now
while we continue to talk through
our application so
then we get to our personal
accomplishments our personal
accomplishments also show a bunch of
data
here if we take a look at the
accomplishments
we will see
that
there is
this data
that's hard coded here
could be very useful to actually move it
to our constants folder and just put it
in there but you'll see how we iterate
using a mapping method over all of our
data and that's exactly how we display
it
so what are the risks that we need to
check for here for example
in this case
should we write another
functional end-to-end test that will
validate that
this
part of our ui correctly reads the data
in the back end
no in this case we don't need to do that
because this data is simply displayed
here
if there's anything weird
that comes out of this like for example
let's say we put one
zero less here and the
amount of
projects here
that will show up in our visual snapshot
and we'll be able to see the differences
and so that's the nice part about the
static data it's being reflected here
and we can capture it again with a
visual end-to-end test that already
exists
protecting us from all of these risks
and then the footer
down here is also very simple so let's
take a look at the footer from the
source code perspective
so the footer is very simple you will
actually see
that we are reusing our social details
component that we've not only written
before but we also have
tested that's why we put it into an
individual component so that we can use
it down here and so of course if we've
already written and tested it to retest
this down here as well no we don't it's
the same exact source code
that we've written and tested before and
so we're good here the only other risk
here is this link that will do a mail to
that could be double checked we could
ensure that this has the correct value
and what would be the best way to do
that we could
simply do a component test to ensure
this has the correct href value and that
would be good enough we could do a
functional end-to-end test with cyprus
but i don't think that in this case is
necessary now i do have one interesting
question for you in terms of a testing
challenge how do we ensure
that these projects links are correct
here so right the view app
if we take a look at the projects
right they're iterating over
two arrays one of which
gets us the source and the visit
from our projects
file
here here are all of our projects right
how do we ensure
that this
url and this url and so on and so forth
are correct
even as we modify
these projects so
one initial thought that i might have is
to do a
functional end-to-end test like we've
done with cyprus right for example if we
come to our our social
details spec
we checked all of our urls in this
manner right in this case making sure
that the ui
is correctly connected to our file and
reading from it correctly however what's
gonna happen when we add a new project
so now we need to add another test and
then the other challenge of that is now
not only do we need to add a new test we
also need to then start adding unique
data test attributes for every single
button that we add
i mean i guess that doesn't necessarily
have to be too much work we could make
it somehow dynamic but that seems like a
lot of extra effort
for testing
just the testing these components here
so instead what we can actually do is
use a component test
specifically a snapshot of our component
to ensure the validity of these
components here and let me show you
exactly what i mean and for that we are
going to use just just which is a unit
testing library that also allows us to
do snapshot tests with the code so let's
take a look at exactly what i mean so
i've configured here
a
snapshot test you can see in our
constants folder i've added a projects
projects.test.js the reason it's called
projects.test because it's testing this
project file that contains all of the
relevant resources and this project
test file
is saying that we're going to have a
test and it's checking that project
details are correct and we're importing
our projects
object and then we're expecting our
project object to match an inline
snapshot so when we initially use this
method in fact i can even show you here
what jest is going to do is generate a
snapshot of this project of course we
can access different properties and so
on and so forth but we really want the
entire object and i'll show you what
that looks like
so if we come here
and of course i already added a script
that's called npm run test jest
it's going to execute this test and what
you also see here is it just filled in
this entire object into our code so it's
written here everything about our object
such as a description the id
the url to the image
but even better it's captured our links
to ensure
that they are correct so similar as with
visual testing all we have to do at this
point is ensure that all of this is
correct one time manually and now from
this point forward we can use the
snapshot as an acceptance criteria for
any future changes and what may a future
change look like for example let's say
that for whatever reason i was in here
and i accidentally
messed up this value and i said
or
i even yeah let's do this first and so
then if we rerun npm
run test jest
we're gonna get a failure
and the failure is going to tell us hey
you expected us to match your inline
snapshot but look at the difference i
found i expected
this
but i got this and so of course that's a
bug and we can reject it so i'm just
gonna go back here and save that and
re-running it of course is gonna pass
beautiful
but then of course even if you wanted to
add a totally new section okay let's
give it a new id
and then rerun just
we're going to get an expected failure
because of course it doesn't match our
snapshot and just is going to tell us
hey i see this totally new object is
this okay so of course you manually
validate that everything works here one
time and then afterwards we now have
this test to ensure that nothing breaks
in the future and with that said we're
able to successfully check everything
all of the data about this section
especially the urls which are hidden of
course everything that's visible can be
captured by our visual test
but the urls are hidden but they can be
checked by our snapshot test and so
with all of that said that captures this
risk and then we never revisited our
apple dashboard let's take a look at
those tests let's take a look at
our new snapshots
we can see our brand new snapshots this
is what they look like now right much
larger everything here looks good
everything looks wonderful to me here so
of course i'm going to accept and now
any future changes we can go in review
them and make sure that nothing is
broken thank you so much for joining me
here today i've been nikolai advalatian
founder of ultimateqa.com where i create
training on coding testing and deploying
web applications it's been a true
pleasure hanging out with you today and
if you have any comments on what you
want to learn next time please go ahead
and comment below and if you want to
learn more from me you can follow me on
my youtube channel
alright see you next time